Vestimentairement parlant, il y a eu deux périodes dans ma vie :
celle où ma mère m'habillait ;
à croire que ma mère choisissait mes vêtements comme ça :
Ooooh mais c'est quoi cette merde...?
Je lui prends !
On peut comprendre que j'ai eu envie d'arriver assez rapidement à la période
où je choisissait mes vêtements, hein, c'était entre le primaire et le collège.
Et là je me suis fait une petite folie !
Hein, j'avais un style assez incroyable
puisque j'avais :
des baskets...
un jean...
un t-shirt...
Voici...
J'adore Coldplay et les films de Quentin Tarantino !
Le gamin le plus normal du monde.
D'ailleurs j'ai pas... trop... changé.
En fait j'aimerais bien avoir un style, un truc un peu original et tout mais...
en fait, non.
J'ai peur que, si je tente,
j'aie cette réaction :
Eh, salut les copains ! Ça va ?
Eh, salut Cypri...
Oh ben...! Qu'est-ce que c'est qu'ça ?! C'est quoi ce...! J'sais pas d'où ça... Pff ! N'importe qu...!
– J'crois que c'est tombé sur moi à un moment.
– Aaaah ouf !
J'avais pas remarqué.
Mais je suis assez admiratif des gens qui arrivent à avoir leur propre style.
Et j'avais un pote au lycée, il est devenu gothique.
Il... C'est... C'était pas mal...!
Le seul truc bizarre, c'est qu'il est devenu gothique du jour au lendemain.
Si ça se trouve, ça peut arriver à tout le monde.
Ben, que le type Eau batte le type Feu, par exemple, ça c'est logique !
Attends une seconde.
Alors que le type Insecte, qui bat le type Psy',
c'est n'importe quoi !
Attends.
C'est comme le type Dragon qui bat le type Dragon, quoi.
C'est... Y'a plus d'idées, quoi.
Ils ont plus d'idées, ouais, c'est ça...
N'empêche c'est quand même important le style vestimentaire, ça...
ça détermine un peu qui tu es, à quel groupe tu veux appartenir.
Ah ben si !
Moi il y a des scènes que j'ai rarement vu, quoi...
que j'ai jamais vu...!
Hier soir j'étais à un vernissage comme je te disais, tu sais que mes parents
possèdent l'appartement au-dessus de la galerie d'exposition.
– Eh frère ! Viens, viens viens !
– Il y avait un débat, il y avait un débat d'idées.
Eh frère, t'as pas une clope ?
Pour mé-fu, t'as pas une clope ?
Encore un fils à papa...
Eh c'est à moi qu'tu parles ? C'est à moi qu'tu parles comme ça ?
Moi la mode, je trouve ça mais vraiment épatant quoi...
Pour qu'un truc soit à la mode, il faut lui donner un nom...!
T'as un truc moche, tu lui donnes un nom, ça devient à la mode !
Attends mais... Ton pantalon il est trop p'tit !
Ah non mais mon pantalon il est pas trop petit, c'est un Slim !
Ah, ah c'est ça, "Slim" ! Ah bah si c'est un Slim, alors ça va !
Désolé, je pensais que c'était un pantalon trop petit mais non c'est un Slim, oui.
Slim !
Attends mais... Ton pantalon il est trop grand !
Il est pas trop grand mon pantalon, c'est un Baggy !
Ah c'est un Bag...! Ah oui, au temps pour moi ! C'est un Baggy ! Ça va alors, si c'est un Baggy...
Ouais. C'est comme lui, il a aussi un Baggy !
Ah non moi par contre, c'est un pantalon trop grand.
Ooh, il porte un pantalon trop grand !
(rires)
Franchement, j'aime bien tous les styles, hein les... les gothiques, les hipsters, les...
sportifs, les gens normaux....
Mais il y a vraiment des trucs que je ne peux pas cautionner.
Je peux pas !
ATTENTION.
À chaque fois que vous retournez le col d'un polo ou d'une chemise pour vous donner un côté "cool",
un chaton
se suicide.
Y'a ça,
et ceux qui portent des lunettes de soleil
la nuit...!
Ces mecs-là, j'ai envie de leur dire :
POURQUOI ?
POURQUOI tu portes des lunettes DE SOLEIL
alors qu'il n'y a PAS
DE
SOLEIL ?
Je... suis aveugle.
Ah...
Ah oui ! Et comme j'en ai marre d'être :
j'ai créé mes propres t-shirts !
Je dessine tous les visuels, et c'est en édition limitée !
C'est q... C'est quoi déjà le site, déjà...?
C'est q... euh...
Ah oui !
Pincez le milieu de l'épaule,
ainsi que le milieu de la ligne parallèle au t-shirt.
Rabattez l'épaule sur l'extrémité,
retournez le t-shirt et mettez-le à plat,
retournez-le une deuxième fois,
C'est bon !
Vous êtes officiellement
le maître du monde.